grab the longer one just pull it to your
hook yeah oh cool like you pull it like
that yeah I'll just quickly finish up
this one Oh check it oh what oh my gosh
she just did there watch me
[Applause]
well Jonah I heard that you brought us
some gifts which is very sweet do you
want to show us yes I hey I heard from a
birdie at Liberty my daughter trying to
die if one of them is mines
starting off of a head for Cedric
[Music]
beautiful
I made a scarf for you and then for
Chanukah I made a pair of fingerless
gloves yarn doesn't make good racing
gloves no yeah what so what about that
green and gold thing you got in there oh
well first I got to finish the gift for
you I thought this is like a white
elephant band that's beautiful
[Applause]
certain colors for your logo and it's a
big Afghan that I only used my fingers
for yes the fingers I will not stop
talking until you subscribe to my
YouTube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this